nous retrouvons antoine claireaux pour
en pulaar les antoine en direct de
moscou c'est bon aucune annonce
importante faite par vladimir poutine
sur la capacité de la russie en armes
ultra rapide oui tout à fait le
président russe s'est exprimé sur ce
sujet justement alors qu'il décorait
herberth efremov un ingénieur qui a
participé à la conception de fusée par
le passé et à entendre vladimir poutine
moscou dispose désormais d'un énorme
avantage militaire sur ses rivaux à
savoir des missiles hypersonique regardé
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
récente la russie possède les types
d'armes les plus modernes qui surpasse
de plusieurs fois par leur force leur
puissance leur vitesse qui est très
important et leur précision toutes
celles qui a existé et existent
aujourd'hui personnes dans le monde
entier n'a de telles armes en tout cas
pour l'instant muet et lors d'un meeting
la nuit dernière vous l'avez évoqué
donald trump a prétendu que si les
russes en était là aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'ils avaient volé des
informations aux états unis du temps de
l'administration obama manière poutine
lui a répondu d'une certaine façon
l'admettant que c'était bien grâce aux
états unis que la russie possède ses
armements à l'heure actuelle mais c'est
plutôt la conséquence d'une décision
prise par washington il ya près de 19
ans qui en est à l'origine
regardez le retrait des etats-unis du
traité anti missiles balistiques en 2002
a forcé la russie a lancé l'élaboration
de barney personnic nous avons dû créer
ses armes en réponse au déploiement par
les états unis d'un système de défense
antimissile stratégique qui à terme
auraient été capables de neutraliser de
mettre à zéro l'ensemble de notre
potentiel nucléaire
voilà donc ce que peut causer le retrait
d'un traité de contrôle des armements
stratégiques
à noter que washington est sortie début
2010 9 du traité sur les forces
nucléaires rapporte intermédiaires et ne
manifeste pas tellement sa volonté de
prolonger le traité new start de
contrôle des armements nucléaires
stratégiques qui lui arrive à échéance
en 2021 avec les conséquences que cela
peut avoir
merci beaucoup antoine pour tous
les précisions antoine claireaux en
direct de moscou